amazon ended up buying a few jets any
thoughts on that amazon decided to come
out and buy
first of all like kai said yesterday
great timing because everything's on
sale right now you know
jets you can pretty much take one from
some of these airlines
amazon buys 11 jets for first time to
ship orders faster amazon said tuesday
that it bought
11 jets from delta and westjet airlines
to boost its grown delivery network and
get orders to shoppers faster
the company said its first time it has
purchased planes for its delivery
network over the past couple of years
amazon has been
leasing place to uh planes to build its
fleet
seattle-based amazon has been working to
deliver most of his packages to sell
reliant
and rely on ups usps and other carriers
amazon 11 planes
the 11 planes they bought all of which
are boeing 76 767
300 will be converted to hold cargo uh
instead of passengers yes what are they
thinking what are they doing they're
just
it's all logistics for them moving this
much freight did you know that they
moved over what was it
1.5 billion packages just over the
holidays
i mean when you stop and think about it
you're crazy when you can order
something on amazon and it's to your
house in an hour
or two hours it's unbelievable but yeah
those are some big planes
i think the the timing of it's just
interesting because i think the price of
planes
has drastically gone down so they were
able to buy these things a little bit
better bargain but
you know it's just like when you go by
an airport and you see all these fedex
planes now you're just going to see
amazon planes you know docked and and
everywhere
i the number one vehicle i pass is an
amazon delivery van i mean probably 15
times a day they're
everywhere and it's funny because it's
been this slow build
it's just like kind of odd all of a
sudden i've just been noticing how
how many of them there are but yeah
well it's fair to say i know who's stuck
i'm definitely shorting and that's fedex
uh ups they can't be happy to hear that
amazon is now buying their own jets and
we're going to be doing their own thing
so
because they've been leasing these other
planes or using them so
their their business is going to see a
major decrease
amazon during covet came up like no
other and elon musk is apparently right
behind jeff bezos about past
about three packs of his wealth crazy
bezos gave 10 million
record-breaking gave 10 billion to
climate change he committed to 10
billion
no he committed 10 billion but he
actually had to spend it last year so
his net worth probably reduced by 10
billion and
elon musk is three billion dollars
behind him right now being the richest
man in the world
the funny thing is here's my exact kai
can you pull up the um
the the time has like a current yeah i
think it's
100 billion this year alone do you think
these guys care
are they keeping scoring wouldn't it
bother me it would totally bother basil
number one anymore i think his
girlfriend would be pissed off at him
of course you know musk is funny because
he says he doesn't really have any like
big spending habits he doesn't really
care about the money that's at least
what he says by the way he just sold
three more homes in california one for
26 million 146 million and one for 25
million so
he sold all his homes i think you wrote
about it in vt post yeah so he had six
homes he had three in bel air he sold
them for 62
million then he sold another handful of
homes that he had in la for like 42
million
so he wanted to not own any homes he's
gonna rent this house in pacific
palisades
355 thousand dollars a month i saw
there's a story on bt post on that too
it's sick so why not man when you got to
come to town that place 355 000 not 350
350 5 000 a month guy cause it's a big
difference
now what's it to him 4 million bucks
four million bucks on the year that he
made a hundred billion dollars
you know the funny thing is where could
elon musk's wealth be one year from now
it could be maybe half of that yeah what
i was saying is i said he can go from
first place to ninth place in no time
because tesla could have a
major drop-off and something happened to
it but well he was uh
will he be the first trillionaire let's
check out this list
jeff bezos 186 billion elon musk
that's a little bit off that's that's
that's off by a day
go up to the top guys when is this one
is this from it'll usually say first
trillionaire will be back at 5pm eastern
yesterday's trading day
so it is really yeah it is real time all
right so he's close
isn't that funny it's like a scoreboard
it's like scroll down
you think they're like let me check to
see what i'm ranking today or they
probably laugh at it going
out it's just like bamboo
what do i say i go down the list we got
jeff bezos we got elon musk number two
we got bernard
arno from france number three that's
lvmh
bill gates number four zuck number five
zhang
shanshan this he's new on the list uh
poor guy lost 276 people larry ellison
number seven in his sleeve
it's outfit number eight basil's he's
got the next big google boys that made
me maybe nobody's gonna do
an electric car that's the top ten where
is our friend
jack ma on this list go to the 50s he's
51.
do you think number 20 people 57 okay is
there money in space exploration
is that a big deal for for what bezos is
doing there
there has to be i would imagine to be
the first one out there
you know what's crazy it's it's all in
mining asteroids
that's where they're saying like the
minerals and the metals that are
on those floating asteroids in space
they're so rich that's where they say
if you get to that point it's game over
like what's in those asteroids kai
minerals you have minerals you have
metals things that
we know and obviously don't know and all
of that gets used to technology
i mean values leave it to our 22 year
old brainiac soon as
as soon as physicist astronaut says
there
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you